having been immersed in the whole
website SEO world for a little while now
what recommendations can give to artists
entrepreneurs actors whatever on
building that presence or is it ok to
just have a facebook damage well there's
two questions there one of them is about
what can you do to make your site better
and in my capacity and digital ad sales
I can tell you some basics find the site
that you really like that's successful
you know is successful and emulate it
you must adhere reinvent the wheel
because you've got what you think is the
right thing to do why don't you go with
what you know his work so i think that
don't reinvent the wheel keep it simple
that's number one regarding this social
network most of the most people are now
focused on social network someone so set
this on twitter so so said this on
facebook that's what's hot right now
will it be that way five years from now
who knows but for now i almost think
that people like short little bits of
information our attention spans are not
big enough to comprehend large amounts
of content that's why tweets are so
popular someone so said this we're
soundbite culture today we're going to
even in the news everything's about
little sound bites a little bit
removable little bits right at you and
that's what that's what works so for now
don't worry about the website too too
much keep it simple you know in radio
needs to have this thing would say it's
not the bumper music in other words your
show doesn't suck because you have bad
bumper music and it's not great because
you have cool like metallica bumper
music hey content he's your content good
is it in demand is it entertaining is it
drawing people in you can have a bad
website phenomenal content you'll do
better than a site that's all show no go
so the fanciest website in the world
cannot cover up add content
same thing in you know if you'll get pop
culture the singing acts out there some
people can't say but they do a great
show but you take someone like Adele now
there's a devil go out there and have
you know ten tons of TNT blasting
fireworks in the air no the girls got
pipes she can sing she's good that's why
she succeeds so you whether or not she's
on youtube I think actually her song for
skyfall is breaking all kinds of records
if she's a phenomenal talent and at the
end of the day no matter whether she's
on youtube or if she's got some fancy
site with blinking lights she'll rise to
the top because she's good and that's
what the where that's always where
the focus should be the quality of the
product
you